J'aime cet endroit et je commence à
croire que c'est là que je suis censé être
la mafia, il y a comme un cancer incurable
neuf secondes c'est ce que je vais te donner
pour décider de ton sort
Je quitterai cet endroit comme une guerre a éclaté
à travers ça je t'attendrai
dépêche-toi cinq quatre
tu me préviens je te prépare
trois deux
l'égaliseur trois arrive bientôt tu aimes
être dans les affaires des autres j'essaye
de m'user dur pour ne pas être tu
y arrive  très difficile pour moi, tu
me préviens, c'est le nerf médian que
je comprime sur une échelle de un à dix,
c'est un deux, c'est un trois,
tu ne veux pas que j'aille à quatre,
toute la mafia viendra te détruire,
je vais  je t'attends The Equalizer
three bientôt au cinéma à cause de
ces gens je commence à comprendre la
vraie paix
quoi qu'il en soit que toi et tes amis le
faites ailleurs vous avez neuf
secondes pour décider face à face
toute la mafia viendra détruire  tu te
dépêches
j'ai l'air d'un tueur
dans la mafia il y a comme un cancer
neuf secondes pour décider de ta foi
je quitte cet endroit comme si une guerre l'avait
traversé je t'attendrai dépêche-toi
The Equalizer trois uniquement au cinéma